Well, we've been calculating
angular momentum about a point.
Recall our definition
of angular momentum.
We've been looking at
cases where the particle is
moving linearly.
Now let's look at a
case where the particles
are undergoing circular motion.
So suppose we have
a particle that's
undergoing circular motion m.
And let's choose some axes.
And our particle, we
denote that it's rotating
about the vertical axis.
I'm going to call
that axis k hat.
And I'll make that omega
squared, omega z positive.
So it's rotating about
the k-axis, the z-axis.
Now, when we calculate
the angular momentum,
we know because it's
rotating about the z-axis,
this is our z-axis, that
the particle has a velocity
tangential to the circle.
So its momentum is
And we draw our vector rs
to where the object is.
Now, you could solve this
in Cartesian coordinates
but then you might have to
do some vector decomposition.
But because there's a central
point to this motion, whenever
there's a central
point we like to choose
cylindrical coordinates.
And the way we'll do that is
we'll define some angle theta.
If this were my plus
x and my plus y-axis,
then that's
consistent with k hat
being up in our
definition of omega.
And I'll define an
r hat unit vector,
which is pointing radially
outward from the center
of the circle.
And a theta hat vector, which
is tangent to the circle.
And now I can calculate--
I can write down, say the
radius of this circle is r.
Then l of s, the vector rs
has radius r pointing outward.
And the momentum vector
is pointing tangential.
And that's a very easy
cross-product to make r hat
cross theta hat.
That's what we're defining
to be k hat, maintaining
the cyclic order.
And so, we get rp k hat.
Now for circular motion
the momentum magnitude
is m, the magnitude of
the theta component.
We've made that positive,
which is mr omega z.
And so ls is--
There's an r here
and another r there.
So we get mr squared
times omega z k hat,
This is our vector omega.
Now this turns out to be the
moment of inertia of a point
particle located at the center.
And so we conclude that
the angular momentum
is proportional to
the angular velocity.
Now, that's no surprise
in this particular case.
Why?
Because the vectors rs and p
are in the plane of motion.
And whenever you
take a cross-product,
l is perpendicular to
both of those vectors
so it's perpendicular
to the plane of motion.
And therefore, l has to
point in the z direction.